uh ladies have a thank you for joining
us here at one uh Carlton Gardens it is
a pleasure to formally welcome U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken to
London this week to join us as we
co-host the Ukraine recovery conference
um it is a great opportunity to catch up
and to compare notes as we do regularly
when we meet various places around the
world
my American counterparts have hosted me
on a number of occasions I felt it was
about time I returned the favor but it
did give us an opportunity to speak
about the situation in Ukraine the
nature of our mutual support to
Ukraine's self-defense efforts against
the Russian federation's brutal and
unprovoked full-scale invasion of
February of last year we also talked
about the recent visit that my prime
minister made to Washington and his
meeting with our American friends
including our course President Biden
himself and the close coordination
corporation that we enjoy across a range
of areas
including the signing of the Atlantic
declaration I also had the opportunity
to get an update from secretary
blinken's recent ship to Beijing and of
course the ongoing work that we do to
try and encourage peace and stability
around the world
is a regular feature of our bilateral
discussions including of course our
ongoing work to prevent Iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon but this week
is very much about encouraging the
private sector
to invest in Ukraine's rebuilding and
Recovery
we recognize that that means that we
need to demonstrate that those
investments will be effective and that
they will be safe and that of course
means the ongoing assurance that the
ukrainians seek that they will not be
reinvaded once they have successfully
regained their territory their further
integration into institutions the
euro-atlantic institutions and European
institutions that they understandably
aspire to but of course it also means
supporting them as they perform the
um reform of their institutions that
will facilitate the investment in their
country one of the things that we have
seen one of the things that we have
witnessed with our support and with our
encouragement the very Swift
transformation of their Armed Forces to
a uh very effective
set of Institutions military
institutions and we want to see that
same alacrity and pace with the reform
of their governmental institutions and
with our help with our support with our
encouragement I have no doubt that they
will replicate the speed of that
transformation
and finally uh whilst it was not a an
area of conversation with Secretary of
Lincoln this afternoon I want to put on
record the UK government's thoughts to
those individuals who are currently in
the submersible in the North Atlantic
we wish we wish them uh all the luck
and of course we hope that they will be
swiftly found and returned to their
loved ones thank you
and I can only Echo that change thank
you
um it's always uh wonderful to be in
London but it's particularly uh
wonderful this time to be
hosted by my friend the foreign
secretary
um
greatly appreciate appreciate that and
especially appreciate your leadership
the UK's leadership on this
reconstruction conference for uh for
Ukraine which brings us together this
week we have more than 50 countries
represented in London for the conference
not just to talk about the importance of
Ukraine recovering from this war but uh
to make sure that it is thriving
as a prosperous democracy and to take
concrete steps in that direction that's
what these couple of days are all about
um President Biden said from the outset
of Russia's aggression against Ukraine
that we would stand with Ukraine for as
long as it takes and both of our
countries are deeply committed to that
we will continue to deliver on that
commitment including through a new
robust U.S assistant package that I'll
be able to announce tomorrow
but as we discussed and as on virtually
everything we are in full alignment
ensuring Ukraine's future as a secure
Sovereign independent nation demands not
only providing for its security
but also for its economy its democracy
and its full integration into Europe
these are really flip sides of the
Ukrainian success coin that we are
helping to deliver on and that's exactly
what's happening here uh this week even
as we're meeting Ukraine's needs on the
battlefield as it continues to defend
and take back territory seized from it
by Russia we're building a military for
the long term so that it has in place
the ability to deter and if necessary
defend against future aggression and
here I just want to again
thank both the the foreign secretary and
all of the UK for the extraordinary
support that it continues to provide
including announcing just last week
another 250 million pounds in additional
security assistance alongside almost 100
million pounds worth of air defense
capabilities
and of course thousands of Ukrainian
soldiers trained in the UK are making a
big difference on the battlefield
but as I said the the flip side of this
is all the work that we are doing here
to help Ukraine prepare for having the
strongest possible economy the strongest
possible democracy which is actually
necessary
to achieve a thriving economy and for
reconstruction if Ukraine is going to
attract the investment it's going to
need not just from governments not just
from International financial
institutions but from the private sector
it has to build the best possible
environment to attract that investment
so we'll be talking about all of that
over the next uh the next two days
we also had an opportunity to talk about
preparations for the NATO Summit that's
upcoming in inglenius and the Practical
steps that we will continue to take to
shore up our own security and Revitalize
the alliance to make sure it's prepared
to meet all of the challenges of this
century
as James mentioned and as all you know I
came to London from Beijing and so we
had an opportunity to discuss the trip
that uh that I just took President Biden
sent me division because he believed
strongly that both the United States and
China have an obligation to manage our
relationship responsibly and that starts
with strengthening lines of
communication across our governments
exploring uh and making clear our
positions and intentions in the places
where we have very significant
differences and also looking at where we
might cooperate together when it's in
our mutual interest and often as well in
the interest of many other countries
around the world we had very candid
substantive
and constructive conversations on each
of these fronts and I think it's clear
that both sides
agreed on the need to try to stabilize
the relationship and we identified
specific areas
where dialogue and cooperation might
benefit
both of us and also other countries
around the world
having said that the the hard work now
of the hard diplomatic work
is going to be entrained to actually
carry this forward
none of these none of the work we're
doing is done in a day or even in two
days even with as much time as we spent
together it's a process and we'll be
engaged in that going forward but here
again
we are in full alignment with um with
our friends and partners if you look at
what prime minister sunac spoke about in
Hiroshima when all of the leaders were
together at G7 and particularly when you
look at what what James spoke about at
mansion house you can see that there is
very clear alignment and not just
between us between virtually all of
Europe
and many countries in in Asia as well
and Beyond and I think that alignment in
the approach that we're taking to the
challenges posed by China is one of the
most important assets that we have uh
going forward
um let me just finally say that as James
mentioned
this visit also comes on the heels of
prime minister sunai's visit to
Washington uh where he and President
Biden announced a new plan for adapting
and reimagining our economies and our
economic partnership for the 21st
century
the Atlantic declaration is Broad
and it's deep
as is our partnership and among other
efforts it will expand our work together
on artificial intelligence something we
talked about over lunch both at the
prime minister's first Global Summit on
AI safety and elsewhere
we're focused together on establishing
guard rails that maximize Innovation to
use AI for good while minimizing the
risks that it represents and we'll work
not just with each other but other
governments with the private sector with
civil society to ensure that AI
capabilities are you safely that they
strengthen human rights and Democratic
Values rather than repress them and that
they Advance Equity not biased
um we're also of course launching
negotiations on a critical minerals
agreement and that will count five
critical minerals extracted or processed
in the UK toward the tax credits that uh
exists now Under The Landmark inflation
reduction Act
that in turn is going to create good
paying jobs on both sides of the
Atlantic in both of our countries while
also meeting the high labor and
environmental standards that we share
and it will help us meet the targets
that we've set to prevent catastrophic
warming of our planet
the agreement like our critical Supply
chains more resilient less dependent on
unreliable governments
so across all of these efforts including
the one that brought me here today
ensuring a secure independent Democratic
and prosperous Ukraine
as always we simply could not ask for a
better partner than the United Kingdom
we're grateful for that and James thank
you for lunch
[Music]
can you explain to us why the United
States is currently unwilling to give
Ukraine an attack onions long range
missiles and why is the United States
pushing to begin stop to work to stay on
those major secretary generals and for a
secretary is the UK willing to give
State backed insurance company to
British firms so that they can help
rebuild your threat while fighting cares
on and can you explain why you're
blocking the release of funds from the
sale of Chelsea Football Club more than
two billion pounds that are designed to
go to help those victims of the war in
Ukraine and
happy to start uh
on uh weapons for Ukraine
at every step along the way of this
aggression by Russia against Ukraine
we've worked to get the ukrainians what
they need to defend themselves and now
as well to take back the territory
that's been seized from them and in fact
that started
even before the aggressions we saw the
storm clouds mounting
um the previous year
we did drawdowns for the kind of
equipment that they needed stingers
javelins and that they had in hand when
the Russians did attack and that enabled
them of course starting with their own
courage and resilience
to keep the Russians out of Kiev to hold
on to their country to push them to the
east to push them to uh to the South but
ever since then
as the battlefield has has changed we've
adapted to that and we are in constant
communication constant dialogue uh along
with about 50 other countries have been
brought together in the Ramstein process
with the ukrainians to make sure that
they have what they need
and different countries are doing
different things to address those needs
and all of that is coordinated at the
same time
I think it's very important that
as always we not get focused on any
particular weapon system because it's
not just the weapon system
it's the training
it's the ability to sustain the systems
that we provide them and then it's the
ability to use them in a coherent way
across all of the different lines of
effort that they're they're making
something that the foreign secretary
knows a lot about given his uh his own
background
and so uh
we will be in constant uh dialogue with
them going forward to make sure that
they are getting what they need and
again I think focusing on any one's
weapon system any one time
I think oversimplifies the the question
and to date I think we've been very
successful
collectively in making sure that Ukraine
has what it needs to maximize its
chances when it comes to the Secretary
General of uh of NATO uh no we have not
we're not pushing promoting any uh
particular candidate we're in very close
consultation with our allies and
partners uh to um to determine where we
want to go with uh with NATO and its
leadership
um
the current Secretary General Ian
stoltenberg has been in President
Biden's eyes a remarkable leader uh NATO
there are also some
rather Extraordinary People now who
people are talking about as the next
Secretary General and that's a decision
that we will all make collectively as an
alliance
uh James I think I'm going to match your
two questions to me together because
ultimately this is about making sure
that Ukraine has what it needs not just
to win this war of survival this uh this
conflict about
their self-defense against Russian
aggression but as Tony said as we
discussed earlier this week is very much
about creating the conditions necessary
for
um
public sector money of course but
predominantly private sector money to
fund their reconstruction now the
precise details of how we do that I
don't want to prejudge the whole point
of the next couple of days is that the
UK uses its expertise as a Global
Financial Services Center including as a
Global Insurance Center but also our
convening power the fact that the U.S
Secretary of State is here and he has
found the time in his unbelievably busy
schedule I think reflects the fact that
the World Views the UK as a good place
to come together to discuss these
complicated issues so I'm not going to
prejudge exactly what vehicles will be
used to unlock both the public and the
private money that Ukraine will need but
as Tony has said ultimately we want to
ensure that the investment that goes
into Ukraine is safe safe from further
conflict and employed as effectively as
possible through robust and reformed
Ukrainian institutions and with regard
to the Risa funds from uh from Chelsea a
foundation has been created and that
will ultimately be responsible for the
distribution of those funds but we are
talking about very very large sums and
I've made it very very clear that I want
to make sure that those funds are
distributed effectively
and to support the Ukrainian victims of
this conflict and it is better when such
significant sums are at stake that we do
it right rather than trying to do it
quick
thank you very much we will now move on
to John Hudson from Washington
John
advantage to watch president
XI
wrestle with some of the biggest issues
and differences between the United
States and China yesterday you got to
meet again with President she listened
to his concerns about U.S policy and
then yourself expressed concerns about
China's policies
do you believe that President Biden used
president XI as the
um
I'm not quite sure how to take that
question John
um
president XI is the leader of China and
in and of itself
that makes him someone of tremendous
significance
on the the world stage
president and president XI have known
each other for for quite some time as
you know when they were both vice
president
they spent time together both in China
and in the United States so there's a a
long relationship there uh good
knowledge of each other
and as I mentioned earlier
I think it's very important that we have
these communications these lines of
communication that are regular that are
sustained that are high level across our
government and the trip this weekend
I think is a demonstration of that and I
suspect that as uh we have more members
of our own government going to China
Chinese officials coming to the United
States uh you'll see the benefits of
that at least in stabilizing the the
relationship making sure that we're
managing it responsibly making sure that
the competition doesn't Veer into
conflict exploring areas of cooperation
but at the end of the day I think that
the relationship and the communication
between the two leaders between
President Biden and president XI is most
important of all that's why they've
had a number of communications and
meetings to date and that's why I expect
you'll see more of that in the time
ahead
watches
senior U.S officials and Senior Chinese
officials talk for more than 10 hours as
they did in the last couple of days and
have substantial conversations about the
war in Ukraine do you think that makes
him nervous well I can't I can't make a
I can't make a a credible estimation of
anyone else's frame of mind
but I think the the broad point about
the importance of Engagement
particularly in turbulent times is uh
absolutely key and I imagine how speech
I made the point that International
engagement matters
secretary Lincoln is doing his job as
the representative of the United States
of America on the world stage engaging
with world leaders and these
counterparts around the world to make
sure
that we can we continue to uh to make
the world a a more safe more prosperous
and less conflicted place and that is
what that's what foreign ministers
that's what foreign ministers do
um but you're right that at the moment
we are very much focusing on the uh on
the war in Ukraine on Russia's brutal
invasion of Ukraine and what we do to
bring that to a swift end and on the uh
the work that we need to do to rebuild
that
thank you very much
presidency do you think that he believes
that
that conflict
so less likely than it was before and to
the um
will you be planning to visit China
yourself in the coming months and
disappoint
do you think you're trying to keep
invited to the artificial intelligence
Summit
um
well just as the foreign secretary said
I can't put thoughts into president
She's mine or anyone else's uh mind so
and I'm certainly not speaking for him
uh so you'd have to ask him that
question what I can say is this I think
both countries
um see the
importance of trying to bring more
stability to the relationship
and certainly the United States is
committed to responsibly managing the
relationship because failure to do that
risks misunderstanding miscalculation
and as I've said risks the competition
we're entering into conflict which is in
no one's interest
um my sense from the long meetings that
we had in China over this weekend
including the meeting with President XI
again is that uh China also sees a
utility and importance in having greater
stability but a lot of work remains to
be done and of course there are very
profound very significant differences
that we have to continue to uh to manage
through we were
very clear that we will stand up
resolutely for our interests and our
values and we had many very very candid
exchanges about places where we have
real differences when it comes to our
own interests our own values which
happen to be the same ones that our
friends have here but also
many other countries around the world
but it's also incumbent upon us to um
communicate clearly I could not agree
more with what the foreign secretary
just said about the imperative
engagement in fact it would be
irresponsible not to engage
uh irresponsible because it makes more
likely the possibility of
misunderstandings miscalculations uh and
and thus conflict it makes it
um virtually impossible for us to work
to advance many of the interests that we
have we had important conversations for
example in our case not only about some
detained Americans and China but also
about the scourge of fentanyl which is
killing more Americans between 18 to 49
than anything else where we hope that
China can play a positive Cooperative
role with us in other countries and
getting a better handle on that so uh
those are just a couple of examples
never mind standing up for human rights
where engagement is absolutely vital
well um briefly just to add to the
broader points that Secretary of
Lincoln's made about the importance of
Engagement in my mansion house speech I
highlighted that engagement was one of
the three pillars of UK's foreign policy
towards China including domestic
protections including building strong
friendships and alliances in the region
and Beyond a big part of the engagement
is of course face to face I've had
face-to-face meetings with Chinese
officials and of course I'm looking at
the options of a potential visit but
there are no details at this stage
thank you very much and time for one
more question from William Morgan uh
Wall Street Journal
uh thank you so much for having us
secretary uh the University of Secretary
of England
um we reported that uh
that
China is preparing a military training
facility in Cuba and was just wondering
that uh the readout of the of the
meeting that we're using
even said that you discussed the two
sides discussed
China's intelligence activities in Cuba
but I'm wondering uh did you discuss
with uh the military activities in Cuba
and whether that would that kind of
action either in the North America
Waters around North America
China
and then for the support secretary I
just want to expand on the BBC's
question beyond the Chelsea funds
there's the UK government regardless of
whether the consensus is reached
to help rebuild the Ukraine and then
also uh just curious whether in your
conversations my colleague Evan Kershaw
which came up who I got to know uh
when he was a resident of London before
he was obtained in Russia has that come
up between you and do you have any
thoughts about how to get Evan back or
how or how to deal with uh
whose careers are for our lives
uh thanks Bill uh yes I uh made very
clear that we would have deep concerns
about uh PRC intelligence or military
activities
in Cuba
since the start of this Administration
we have engaged
a number of countries where we've seen
consideration of having some kind of uh
Presence by China intelligence military
and we've engaged in a number of
diplomatic efforts in that regard and I
think they've had some success in
slowing down these efforts this is
something we're going to be monitoring
very very closely and we've been very
clear about that and we will protect our
homeland we will protect our interests
uh thank you on uh on the situation with
regards to the rebuilding of a Ukraine
uh as I've said we we recognize the
governments have a role to play uh we
feel the private sector has a role to
play but there are I think there is a a
very strong principle of natural Justice
uh whereby a significant perhaps even
the majority burden for the rebuilding
should sit on the shoulders of those who
have uh either been responsible for
funding or facilitated this uh brutal
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
earlier on this week yesterday in fact
the UK passed uh secretary legislation
which meant that we can we can continue
to freeze sanctioned assets until
reparations are made by those
individuals whose assets have been
sanctioned uh it follows that simple
premise that you know you break it you
bought it and I think it's absolutely
appropriate that those who have uh in
whatever way facilitated this Invasion
bear
the responsibility for making good on
um on the Reconstruction effort with
regard to Heaven uh actually this was an
issue that came up on my most recent
visit to Washington I spoke extensively
at the UK's Embassy in Washington uh in
front of an assembled
reception of journalists the UK's
position on press freedom and the
protection of journalists is
long-standing and uh and and I very much
reflect that today
um the way Nations treat journalists
is the canary in the mine
to the the the way they treat citizens
more broadly
where journalists are free to scrutinize
criticize publicize that shows a healthy
Society where journalists are murdered
abducted or illegitimately imprisoned it
is a very very uh concerning marker
sadly the situation in Russia we know is
not a
benign environment for journalists and
Truth tellers and the UK's position on
the protection of journalists and
remains
absolutely unwavering
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
your time thank you
foreign